avec jean marc coppola candidat du
printemps marseillais dans le 8e secteur
de marseille
bonsoir jean marc coppola merci des
trafiquants sur rt france alors on
attend évidemment votre réaction une
femme la première à être à la tête de la
ville de marseille et à gauche
absolument oui je crois qu'il faut
vraiment souligner dans la deuxième
ville de france à avoir une femme quand
vous regardez sur le fronton à
l'intérieur du conseil municipal
l'ensemble des maires de la ville depuis
deux cents ans plus de 200 ans
c'est quand même assez fabuleux et puis
c'est elle est à la tête surtout d'un
rassemblement des forces de gauche
progressiste écologiste et citoyenne
c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de femmes
qui se sont qui ont tiré leur épingle du
jeu de cette élection municipale
marseille tourner la page de jean claude
gaudin marseille tourner la page sur
quoi précisément selon lui marseille
tourne à la page surtout de 25 années
d'incurie de gestion de retard dans tous
les domaines que ce soit dans la gestion
des écoles que ce soit dans la gestion
de l'habitat indigne en 25 années les
inégalités sociales et territoriales se
sont creusées et donc c'est
insupportable que dans la deuxième ville
de france cette ville portait sur la
méditerranée il y ait deux cent
cinquante mille personnes en dessous du
seuil de pauvreté
et donc il y avait beaucoup d'attentes
il ya beaucoup d'urgences et je pense
que c'est à la fois la réponse à ces
urgences que nous avons porté dans dans
notre projet mais aussi une autre façon
de pratiquer la politique c'est à dire
une avec plus de démocratie citoyenne et
puis tourner la page de 25 années aussi
de d'un système et donc voilà nous
sommes vraiment très heureux et de
l'allier c'est pas simplement dans
l'hémicycle avec les élus du printemps
marseillais mais elles étaient dans la
rue je peux vous dire que des
marseillais et des marseillais ont
attendu 6 7h 8h le verdict et c'est
justement toute cette foule qui nous
apportait qui aujourd'hui est libérée
mais c'est vrai que ça a été une
élection un conseil municipal assez
compliqué au final
on peut dire que michel roux viraux là
et bien élu ou pas oui le biais des lui
puisque nous avions avec ce mode de
scrutin
j'allais dire et des élections par
secteur les huit secteurs à marseille
nous arrivions largement trail en tête
avec plus de 13 mille voix par rapport à
la droite et nous recueillons que 40 et
1 42 élus pardon sur 101
donc on avait une majorité relative vous
voulez avoir une majorité absolue pour
que effectivement dans toute la ville
nous puissions mettre en oeuvre notre
programme et surtout une nouvelle façon
de pratiquer la politique avec beaucoup
de des tic et donc on sait la
responsabilité les chantiers qui sont
devant nous mais je peux vous dire qu'on
est vraiment déterminés on sait que on a
une majorité de marseillaise qui va nous
supporter et qui va dans le bon sens
dans ses supporters comme l'om on a vu
on a vu le rassemblement national
stéphane ravier claqué la porte du
conseil municipal lui c'était des petits
arrangements entre amis finalement le
débat il n'a pas eu lieu vous êtes
d'accord
et disons que d'abord la dans la mise en
place d'un conseil municipal l'élection
du maire de la mer en occurrence il n'y
a pas de débat et surtout je pense qu'il
est frustré de ne pas avoir réussi un
accord lui dans la nuit avec la droite
pour essayer de voler le l'expression
majoritaire des marseillais puisque
c'est la gauche qui est arrivé largement
en tête et donc ils auraient bien voulu
lui justement volée 7/7 démocratie et
les cette démocratie qui est déjà assez
piétiné comme ça avec 65 % d'abstention
c'est d'ailleurs un phénomène au niveau
national sur lequel il faut sur lequel
il faut réfléchir et nous nous avons
vraiment l'intention de réhabiliter la
politique pour que les citoyennes et les
citoyens réinvesti ce champ de la
démocratie alors il ya cette question de
l'écologie à votre mouvement s'appelle
le printemps marseillais faut-il y voir
une touche verte
absolument nous voulons une ville le
plus juste d'abord lutter contre les
inégalités mais c'est aussi plus verte
et lors la matière quand on voit cette
ville
pollué dans tous les sens du terme
encombrée par trop de véhicules et qui
est pourtant sur les bords de la
méditerranée
eh bien nous avons de beaux chantiers
devant nous donc c'est la justice
justice sociale progrès social une plus
d'écologie et d'environnement
et puis plus de démocratie aussi et donc
voilà nous avons vraiment une belle
ambition à mettre en oeuvre maintenant
un des enjeux est annoncée la sécurité
dans certains quartiers à marseille vous
avez déjà des réponses oui je crois que
les réponses passe par la lutte contre
le chômage
on sait très bien l'égalité qu'il ya
entre délinquance enfin chômage et
délinquance
et donc ça passe par l'ugtt est
justement contre la précarité le chômage
et puis mettre beaucoup plus j'allais
dire de d'humain dans les liens dans les
liens sociaux
ça passe par des médiateurs et ça passe
aussi par bien entendu des forces de
police mais des forces de police de
proximité et pas simplement dans la
répression et les caméras dont on a vu
les limites de 7,2 c'est à ce moment là
merci beaucoup jean marc coppola avoir
répondu à nos questions si tardivement
sur rt france merci